امام السيد امين مهمه معقده يقع على عاتقه
الكشف عن وضع المباني في المدينه
التوصيات التي سيخرج بها سيستند اليها في
اتخاذ قرار بهدم البنايات او اعلانها
صالحه للسكن
هذا التواء في الحديد في اساس المبنى
هنا مشكله التواء ايضا
وزاره البيئه التركيه نشرت فرقا ميدانيه
للتحقق من سلامه المباني وتحديد تلك التي
يجب هدمها
هناك سببان للضرر احدهما الزلزال والثاني
مشكله في سلامه البناء منذ انشائه
الاكبر في ديار بكر هو ضرر بعيد الامد غير
بعيد عن عمليات الكشف في المباني بالمدينه
تعيش مئات العائلات في خيم مؤقته وفي وضع
يزيد الشتاء من قسوته اكثر من الف مبنى
اخلي من السكان وهنا تتبلور ماساه الاخلاء
فجرا ولم نعد حتى الان اعمده المنزل
متضرره
اقفلنا منزلنا منذ اليوم الاول لا نعرف
وضعه حاليا
وكانت وزاره العدل التركيه اعلنت انها
انشات مكاتب للتحقيق في ادعاءات اهمال قد
يكون السبب وراء انهيار مباني وتضرر اخرى
سلام خضر الجزيره ديار بكر